- You look like me if I
was a Trump supporter.
Do you love America?
- Sure, look at my hat.
- I don't know what
I was thinking.
(military marching music)
Who are you voting for?
- T-R-U-M-P, Trump.
- Great, thank you
for spelling it.
- Go Trump.
His name's not Hillary.
- Neither is Bernie's.
- Yeah but he's a socialist.
- Okay, what does that mean?
(stutters)
- He's just not good.
Like, I don't like him at all.
- Okay.
(explosion)
- So we're talking about
the role of sex in politics
and I wanna know,
do you think Trump
is attractive?
- Yes.
- Good looking guy,
cleans up well.
- Do you think that
matters in a candidate?
- No.
- Do you think
Hillary is attractive?
- No.
- Do you think it
matters for her?
- Maybe.
- You don't want
a female president
unless she's kinda
bangable, right?
What about Hillary?
- If she were a man,
perhaps a five.
Woman?
We'll give her a three.
- If she was a man,
she'd be hotter?
Do you think Trump
is an attractive man?
- You know what?
I have never even
thought about it.
- Well, do you think Hillary
is an attractive woman?
- I do not.
- You have considered that.
- I have considered that.
- What kind of sex do
you think Trump has?
- Can you imagine
somebody come and ask you
what kind of sex you like?
- I like--
- No, don't answer me!
- Anal, doggy.
- Don't answer me.
Don't answer me.
- Do you think he has
sex or makes love?
- Probably number two.
- He probably does number two.
- He's doing number
two all over Melania.
- She's so beautiful,
it could be number one as well.
- Okay, yeah you're
right, you're right.
- Who will you be
voting for in November?
- Donald Trump.
I've already endorsed him.
- What are you?
- I'm running for the United
States Senate, California.
- Would you perform
a sex act on Trump?
If it meant he
would for sure win?
- I wouldn't.
I wouldn't even answer
the question, I mean...
- Would you just kiss it?
- No, I don't think
this is appropriate.
- Right, right.
- Would you kiss Donald
Trump on the penis
if it mean Isis would disappear?
- Easily, yeah.
- Oh, to get rid of Isis?
Of course.
- Would you go down on Hillary?
- Oh no.
- Oh God, no.
- I am not a Hillary
supporter, so.
- Okay.
He's had four wives.
Three wives?
Four wives, I can't...
Four bankruptcies, three
wives, sorry, okay.
But you're still into him
even though he's
gonna build that wall
and he thinks
Mexicans are rapists.
- He might change his mind.
- He does that a lot.
That's true.
- What do you think
his dick is like?
- White.
- That's all that matters.
- That's all that
matters, right, exactly.
- And what ethnicity are you?
- I am Mexican.
Mexican.
- But being white
is most important.
- Exactly, yes.
Yes, yes, yes, yes.
- So, do you want to
make America horny again?
- Why not?
- Are you ready to make
America horny again?
- I'm always horny.
- Make America horny again.
- Who wants to make
America horny again?
(crowd cheers)
Yeah!
Make America horny again!
Trump would hate you.
(explosion)